[Music]
where am i gonna do it
what am i gonna do
here guys
[Music]
and we are going to run out of stock if
you don't act soon i know what you're
wondering out of stock let me explain
once we our target to pay for the prayer
mats and the workshop we don't need any
more donations which means you won't be
able to sponsor someone and reap that
reward every single time they pray some
of these people have taken shahada with
us we teach them how to do with learn
the actions of salah we help them
memorize the surah fatiha in arabic
providing them with a prayer path but
most importantly spending quality time
mentoring them imagine every time they
pray it will be on your scale every
single salah for the rest of their life
not only that when they teach their kids
and their grandkids guess who scale it's
on yours oh and before i forget we're
also launching our online prayer course
which will push the 700 000 plus people
online and guess what it will be
available for people to watch around the
world imagine new muslims learning salah
from around the world from japan to
mexico and you will never know that was
all because of you until the day of
judgement we're looking for just 1 000
people to give 100 pounds each to allow
us to teach 10 000 people how to pray
their salah will allah choose you to be
one of them click the button or the link
and donate now